et puis cette question que les
contribuables se pose comment l'argent
des contrats de plan est il utilisé la
lorraine par exemple vient de recevoir
une enveloppe de plus de quatre
milliards et demi de francs
insuffisant a estimé cet après midi le
président udf de la région gérard
longuet qui rappelle que la reconversion
du textile et de la sidérurgie reste
inachevée en lorraine l'emploi est la
priorité ce reportage de marbre coeur et
christian welter
c'est sur ce qui a été réalisé 1965
si les rues rhji et charbon employés 106
mille personnes aujourd'hui il en reste
à peine dix minutes 1992 les logements
des mineurs de cormontaigne son
dynamiter le symbole de la fin d'une
époque 1995 reconversion réussie
le site s'est mutée en pôles
technologiques mecanica est né grâce au
contrat de plan etat-région 10 millions
de francs répartis entre états lorraine
et europe objectif conseiller les
entreprises pour améliorer les débouchés
et donc l'emploi 1200 entreprises
attendent de nous à la fois une vision
d'avenir des méthodologies des
ressources en termes de compétences pour
leur permettre de mieux concrétiser
leurs projets de développement qui
créeront l'emploi de demain à
saint-avold
le pôle de plasturgie spécialiste du
soudage des matériaux plastiques par
ultrasons coques de navires ou cabines
de camion bénéficie depuis dix ans de la
manne des contrats de plan l'état est un
interlocuteur quotidien met pas un frein
aux performances et à la rentabilité
la structure pôle de plasturgie
fonctionne comme une entreprise c'est à
dire elle a les mêmes critères
d'autofinancement pour son
fonctionnement qui est un des éléments
indispensables à sa survie
je me sens dans une société privée puis
dans la main mise de l'état je la
ressens un état qui après large
concertation régionale de préparation du
contrat de plan accorde la priorité au
développement économique
nous sommes aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
impliqué sur les questions de cohésion
sociale et territoriale par exemple pour
le développement de l'emploi que sur des
problèmes strictement des tombes bitume
la priorité des singes et des autres
c'est l'emploi donc on est d'accord sur
les objectifs on mobilise toutes nos
énergies et tous nos moyens sur ses
objectifs prioritaires donc globalement
c'est vrai l'argent des contribuables
est plutôt bien utiliser les aides de
l'europe à la région sont en déclin ce
contrat de plan etat-région bien négocié
et maîtrisée devrait permettre à la
lorraine de surmonter ce handicap